The first Earthlings sent into space were
brave, calm under pressure, and heroic.
They were also not human and many of them
were furry.
Yes, before Apollo 13, Buzz Aldrin, Neil Armstrong,
and Yuri Gagarin, humans sent fruit flies,
monkeys, and dogs into space to determine
if living beings could survive the trip.
These tests helped prove that, given a certain
amount of precautions and protections, humans
could endure space flight.
Here is the little told story of these mostly
cute and cuddly astronauts.
The V-2 rocket developed by the Germans was
the first man-made object to reach the so-called
fringes of space.
The first test flight of this massive rocket
was in May of 1944.
When successful (at least, by standards of
the day), it was rushed into war.
By August 1944, Nazi Germany was raining down
V-2 rockets onto the city of London.
Upon the end of the war, the allied forces
were quite familiar with the potential of
these V-2 rockets and scoured the world for
V-2 rocket parts, as well as German engineers
and scientists who knew how to build them.
It became a competition between Britain, the
US, and the Soviet Union to see who could
develop their own, better, version of the
V-2 the quickest.
As the Cold War heated up between the Soviets
and the Americas, it also became a matter
of national security.
(See: How Did the Cold War Start and End?)
On February 20, 1947, a mere 22 months after
Germany’s surrender, the United States launched
a captured V-2 rocket with fruit flies aboard.
These fruit flies were the first Earthly beings,
outside of microbes, in space.
From its launch site in New Mexico, the rocket
traveled to an altitude of about 68 miles
(going past the Karman line) on a three minute,
ten second suborbital mission.
The purpose of this test was to determine
the effects of high acceleration and cosmic
radiation exposure on living beings.
When the scientists retrieved the rocket,
they found the fruit flies alive and well.
Sixteen months later, in June of 1948, the
United States upped the ante by sending Albert,
a rhesus monkey, on trip aboard a V-2 rocket.
Nine pounds and anesthetized, he was placed
in the nose of the V-2, which only went to
an altitude of 39 miles.
Unfortunately, scientists and his human handlers
speculated that he died even before take-off,
having suffocated in the cramped capsule.
Even if he was alive, the parachute mechanism
failed and the rocket had a violent crash
landing.
At least the name “Albert” lived on because,
from that point on, the proceeding tests involving
monkeys in the United States were known as
the “Albert project.”
Almost exactly a year later, the US tried
again.
They sent another rhesus monkey, appropriately
named Albert II, into the sky aboard a V-2.
This time, they gave him more breathing room
with a less cramped space.
Also anesthetized, he reached an altitude
of 83 miles, making him the first primate
in space.
While he was alive through about 99 percent
of the flight, he was killed upon impact when,
once again, the parachute mechanism failed
to work properly.
It was around this time that the Soviet Union
were planning the next evolution of “biological
objects” being sent into space.
Under the utmost secrecy due to the fear of
spies, to the point that even many of the
scientists working on the project didn’t
know exactly what was going on, the Soviets
were preparing to send dogs into the great
beyond.
Called “future space scouts,” their reasoning
for selecting dogs was more practical and
cost-efficient than science-based.
First of all, as stated later by Vladimir
Yazdovsky, the head of the biological program
for space research at the Institute for Aviation
Medicine in Moscow:
We selected dogs as biological objects because
their psychology is very well-studied, they
adapt well to training, are very communicative,
and social with people.
Also, they were plentiful and cheap.
Moscow was awash with stray dogs and finding
ones to meet the space program’s exact specifications
wasn’t particularly hard.
The dogs had to be healthy, adults, between
thirteen and fifteen pounds, light coat color
(more easily seen in photos, which was a huge
part of the publicity), mixed-breed (for their
supposed “hardiness”), and female.
(Female dogs’ anatomy made it easier for
the suit and “sanitation equipment” to
be properly fitted.)
The dogs were trained for space travel by
being put in smaller and smaller crates, which
was an attempt to get them accustomed to the
restrictive space they would have to be in
during flight.
They also had to get used to all the suits,
contraptions, and equipment they would be
wearing, including a cumbersome “sanitation
device.”
They were fed an energy gelatinous food, made
up of bread crumbs, powdered meat, and beef
fat.
Many of the dogs simply didn’t react well
to all of this and were not allowed to train.
The ones that did had numerous health issues
later, including kidney failure and constipation.
Dezik and TsyganIn 1951, the first two dogs
– Dezik and Tsygan (Russian for “Gypsy,”
see: Where Did the Gypsies Originally Come
From?) – were launched, reaching an altitude
of 62 miles.
Upon coming back to Earth, the parachute deployed
correctly.
When the scientists opened the hatch, they
were greeted by barking.
Dezik and Tsygan had survived, becoming the
first living beings outside of flies successfully
recovered from a spaceflight.
The next week, Dezik was sent on another flight
with a dog named Lisa.
All was fine until the parachute failed to
deploy.
They were both killed.
Upon learning about the accident, the head
of the Commission for the Investigation of
the Upper Atmosphere, Anatoli Blagonravov,
declared that Tsygan was going to be retired
from space flight and come home with him to
be his pet.
After Dezik and Tsygan, the Soviets would
send many dogs into space over the next six
years.
A few died due to mechanical failures, but
many survived.
The scientists and engineers studied the dogs’
vital signs, their post-flight health checkups,
and observed the massive amount of film taken
during the flights.
They learned that while the dogs got agitated,
disoriented, and perhaps a tad motion sick,
they were pretty much okay health-wise during
space flight.
This set the stage for Latka and her travels
aboard Sputnik 2.
LaikaKudryavka or “Laika” which was Russian
for “barker,” initially wasn’t the best
candidate for the historic flight and the
designation of being the “most famous dog
in history.”
Another mutt named Albina was, but according
to the book Animals in Space: From Research
Rockets to the Space Shuttle, she just had
a litter of puppies and was everyone’s favorite.
The scientists didn’t want to sacrifice
her for what was a suicide mission.
Latka was highly sociable, patient, and scored
well under harsh circumstances.
So she was chosen.
Laika was put under intense training and preparation
leading up to her flight.
She had electrodes inserted into her to detect
vital signs and heart activity.
She was fitted for suits and held in preparation
crates.
On October 4, 1957, about a month before Lika’s
launch, Sputnik I launched into the skies
and became the first artificial Earth satellite
in space.
This energized the Soviet people and when
Laika was first introduced via radio to the
population on October 27, 1957, she delightfully
barked into the microphone.
Posters, figurines, and even comic books were
quickly mocked up with Laika’s likeness.
She was the most famous dog in history and
ready to go to space.
Laika was kept in the capsule for three days
before she was launched.
During this time, her handlers were so concerned
about her that they had to beg the head engineer
to give her squirts of water to ensure she
survived until take-off.
Finally, on November 4th, she and Sputnik
2 was launched.
Now, according to records at the time, Laika
was the first Earth-born living creature to
go into orbit.
This may not be entirely truthful.
According to reports that only came out in
2002, Laika may have perished about five hours
into the flight due to overheating (thermal
insulation failure) and possibly even stress
exacerbated by overheating.
It is not known if she was even alive while
Sputnik 2 orbited.
This was not made public knowledge at the
time, as the world’s newspapers carried
headlines much like this one from the New
York Times, “Soviet Fires New Satellite
Carrying Dog.”
In fact, as Sputnik orbited over the next
four days, Russian press releases kept referencing
Laika’s good condition.
Regardless of when she died, Laika was, controversially,
never meant to be recovered, and after 2,570
orbits, on April 14, 1958, Sputnik 2 broke
apart and disintegrated in the Earth’s atmosphere.
One of the scientists involved in Laika’s
mission, Oleg Gazenko, later stated of this,
“Work with animals is a source of suffering
to all of us…
The more time passes, the more I’m sorry
about it.
We shouldn’t have done it…
We did not learn enough from this mission
to justify the death of the dog.”
Meanwhile, the Americans still had monkeys.
They kept sending different types of primates
into space throughout the 1950s, with most
of them resulting in fatalities.
The most famous and successful of these experiments
was the May of 1959 launch of Abel, a rhesus
monkey, and Miss Baker, a squirrel monkey.
Their safe landing made them the first primates
to return safely to Earth after traveling
in space.
Unfortunately, Abel died several days after
returning to Earth during a procedure to remove
the electrodes implanted in her body.
After her death, she was prepared by a taxidermist
and her body is currently on display at the
Smithsonian’s National Air and Space Museum
strapped into the harness that took her into
space.
Miss Baker, on the other hand, lived another
twenty five years, mostly at the U.S. Space
and Rocket Center in Huntsville, Ala.
When she passed away in 1984, over three hundred
people attended her funeral service.
After the Soviet Union’s Yuri Gagarin became
the first human to orbit the Earth on April
12, 1961, there was much less of a need for
monkeys and dogs to strap on spacesuits.
The age of manned space flight had dawned.
Nonetheless, a chimpanzee, mice, a cat, bull
frogs, newts, spiders, and many other animals
have all been sent into space over the years
for various scientific reasons.
But one should not forget that Earth’s first
headline space travelers were not humans,
but fruit flies, monkeys, and dogs.
The Karman Line, named after Hungarian-American
physicist Theodore von Karman, is the boundary
that exists 62 miles above sea level and is
generally accepted as the line between the
Earth’s atmosphere and outer space.